hey david hi graham nice to see you nice
to see you i'm a big fan
it's real honor to meet you even if it
is virtually oh thank you i appreciate
that
now i got to ask you first what was
going through your head
when yu jung yoon's acceptance speech of
the bath does when you said that thing
about
snobbish brits what were you thinking i
was saying she is so
right that's what i was thinking
and i'm glad someone said it
that was an amazing moment i had to ask
you with that so directorial debut like
does this feel
different than if you're just acting as
something like is there more nerves
like putting this out there because it's
your directorial debut yeah i am so
nervous graham i i wish i wish i could
say
it's it's it's otherwise it's it is
completely different you know because
with being an actor you can hide behind
the director the writing the
cinematography the marketing the studio
the release date you know whatever it is
there's a myriad of reasons why
it doesn't go as well as you would hope
but as a director at the end of the day
the buck stops with you uh you're the
captain of the ship and you go
down with it or you're celebrated with
it and that's just one of the things you
have to accept
when you direct a movie so yes i'm
nervous but i will say i'm proud of what
we created
yeah you should be absolutely and so uh
harper films was the production company
around this and oprah's one of the
executive producers
i mean you guys have been working
together for several years now like what
is it that keeps
bringing you guys back together because
obviously both you work with a lot of
different people
like what is that connection it keeps
bringing you two back together on
different projects
we really share a sensibility um you
know
we we share a world view but i think
above and beyond
that she's just been a guardian angel
for me um
i i one of the biggest blessings of my
life is the fact that she just
consistently
wants to support me protect me advise me
and you know can you think of a better
person on planet right
have those things from i mean i'm
literally the best
most blessed man i know for having that
and so when i
approached her with this story to be
perfectly frank the thing that really
made her want to participate is the fact
that it's something i was passionate
about
and she's been very helpful with notes
and her advocacy and
you know all those things that she gives
me in life she's also let me
in art yeah that's awesome and really
there's a huge family connection too
because i guess
jessica did three songs in the movie
and then asher produced the end credit
song right so
how did that come about that they all
were involved in the music wow you've
done your research that is exactly right
um
yeah my wife jessica she actually wrote
the lullaby
that uh rosario's character sings to
lonnie on the bed early in the film that
was actually a song that she wrote for
my second son caleb
when he used to suffer with nightmares
as a little kid
um and then she um wrote this uh the end
credit song that my son asha
um produced um uh i called my son
and then um and then has done
a film called what love does uh inspired
by the movie
that is coming out soon as well so yeah
it was very much a family affair they
were with me while we were shooting my
dad was there my kids were there
um you know and and that's the way i
like to have it
yeah it's amazing so do you have the
directing bug now
i do i do but for the right thing you
know i'm
not intending to suddenly be uh
predominantly or
exclusively a director um but it's gonna
be things that i'm very passionate about
you know if you're gonna direct a film
you better love that movie because
you're gonna be spending a lot of time
with it and i'm thankful with the
waterman that there was never a day that
i got tired of it and every day that i
thought why did i do this
you know they're just themes in there
actors involved
crew involved financiers um and just
participants who i just deeply love
their contribution
i never felt bored of it and i think it
would be hellacious to be in a situation
where you're stuck with the thing you
don't like so
you know i'll be picky and judicious but
i yeah i've definitely got the bug
you